[Musique]
vous dirigez service de réanimation de
salpêtrière à paris quelle est la
situation dans votre service elle est un
peu catastrophique
on n'a jamais eu autant de patience
point de critique sous l'île de france
depuis le début des crises même dire
qu'on n'y croit pas dans la première il
compris pendant la première vague on ne
voit aucun reflux dans les services de
réanimation une interview du président
paraît demain dans la presse régionale
mais le calendrier a fuité dès cet après
midi
première étape le 3 mai la levée
notamment des restrictions de
déplacement
puis rendez vous le 19 couvre-feu
repoussé à 21h et réouverture des
commerces et terrasses là pour le coup
on n'est pas du tout dans ce que j'avais
imaginé mais je vous remets chakras et
je fais un petit siège tu as raison
stéphanie ouf d accra on a bien entendu
rembobinons ouvre t à crabes et les
acras naziha c'est pour la morue il n'y
aura plus de couvre-feu tel qu'on le
connaît au delà du 2 juin sans entrer
dans le détail il ya des raisons
juridiques et que le cadre légal ne sera
plus possible au delà du 2 juin ça veut
dire que la première soirée au plus tard
le 2 juin en soir nous n'aurons plus de
couvre-feu tel qu'il est tel qu'il est
en place depuis depuis six mois
maintenant je veux dire qu'on donne de
l'espoir
ce gouvernement merci genty président de
la république nous donner de l'espoir
moi j'aurais préféré qu'ils nous donnent
des solutions mais elle me donne de
l'espoir
vous êtes tous devenus fous elle a
basculé dans le monde d'après dans l'ère
du post le poste droit le poste
sanitaire le poste aux logiques on est
dans le monde d'après la blague ne fait
pas rire grand monde
une influence en vacances à bali c'est
pas un masque sur le visage pour faire
ses courses dans un supermarché de l'île
où le port du masque est obligatoire
la vidéo filmée par un complice fait
grand bruit en indonésie les autorités
réfléchissent même à une possible
expulsion des deux individus chacun dans
son pays d'origine elle en russie hui à
taïwan
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
changement total d'ambiance dans leurs
dernières publications pour calmer le
jeu le duo s'affiche vrai masque sur le
nez aux côtés de leurs avocats pour
s'excuser platement
tiens j'ai pas mis mon casque
[Musique]
y avait un trou chefs dont tu as fait tu
conviens la tête
c'est vrai au maire de châtillon en
revanche certains ont cru être vacciné
je dis bien ont cru mais l'ont pas reçus
l'injection en fait des eaux une
injection mais à l'intérieur il y avait
que du sérum physiologique
les préparateurs ont oublié d'ajouter le
vaccin contre le coc vie d'une piqûre
pour rien donc pour 54 personnes mais
n'inquiétait pas non non non je suis pas
du tout et qu'il juste paniquer cg oui
c'est ça ok c'est marca dieu non là j'ai
envie de pleurer à crier bientôt
vaccinés oui oui on a tous décidé
combien y at il de ce alors là oui ah ah
oui alors quand je dis quand je dis ça
après il ya des gens extrêmement
intelligents qui font un complotiste à
la solde du gouvernement sur sa mort le
monde juste envie d'être en bonne santé
ça et j'ai le droit de répondre je
m'efface où tu vas entendre m'empêcher
de parler franchement vous me parlez pas
comme ça je peux pas le comme je veux
maintenant quand on regarde simplement
intérieur encore une fois maîtresse je
vous demande de sortir du conseil
municipal je suis madame la maire
[Musique]
aléatoire ta s'étend depuis seulement
avaient entre est ce que la femme a le
droit de porter des pantalons
avant cela un texte de 1800 imposée à la
femme de demander l'autorisation de se
travestir de son département pour que ce
soit un peu plus chic répression la fin
je suis persuadé qu'une hâte c'est pas
très vite montré les culottes à ma
chérie samedi 1er mai oui ce sera la
seizième édition du world naked garden
inn today en cette journée mondiale du
jardinage nu lancé par des jardiniers
américain est aujourd'hui largement mise
en avant par les naturistes français
l'objectif de cette journée est je cite
de renforcer le lien entre l'humain et
la nature
ce battage et c'est de préparer le café
par contre c'est vraiment pas évident
voilà enfin un café dans la forêt déjà
pour allumer les allumoirs c'est la
galère je sais pas du tout faire du café
et donc que je fais n'importe quoi
ça va des glaces mais bon voilà c'est
geste qui compte face à cet homme en
détresse
bruno est compréhensif il tente même de
créer un lien grâce à l'humour
le breton l'alcool voit la peinture
c'est trop ça c'est des cafés corse
et c'est dedans j'ai mis de l'eau
pétillante a fait corps
moi je suis déçu voilà je vais pas y
aller par quatre chemins je suis je suis
déçu de ton plat on est sereins en plein
qui doit être rustique le plat du pauvre
savait pas dire un plat sans goût c'est
pas parce qu'on est pauvre qu'on peut
manger de la merde
voici la propriété qui fait tant parler
170 hectares dont 4 de vignes et un
acheteur dont le nom est sur toutes les
lèvres
sur ce coup non mais c'est à brignoles
dans le var que george clooney et sa
femme amal vont poser leurs bagages
la commune de 17000 habitants est située
à équidistance de saint tropez de
marseille alors lors de notre
emménagement il m'a annoncé ma que la
veille il avait une aventure d'une
soirée mais ça dure avec une soirée a
donc voudra soir le fameux l'acteur
américain met ses pas dans ceux de
george lucas ce mais aussi d' angelina
jolie et brad pitt qui habite le
département dans une boutique de la
commune ont dit avoir déjà reçu une
visite très importante
on va t'il est arrivé voulez vous
acheter un petit changement qu'on est
ici et là près tous les équipements qui
doivent écouter un majeur de l'américain
nom et par les français que l'info c'est
que j'en prenais une chicha famille ici
présence insectes à moi pour vous et
vous c'était une très bonne fin d'après
midi sur france 2 antennes depuis 1992
je vous ai connu